[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
should the derek chauvin trial jury be
sequestered there's
civil unrest and maybe some of the
jurors did hear about that
the shocking body cam video of a police
officer shooting and killing a
20-year-old man
just miles from the minneapolis
courthouse
what the brooklyn center police chief is
saying about the dante wright case
this was an accidental discharge that
resulted in a tragic death of mr right
our legal analysis on whether this case
could have an impact on the chauvin
trial
plus the continuing coverage of our
investigation into the man seen in the
car with george floyd on the day he died
why maurice hall is in jail on sex
trafficking charges
and will chauvin's defense call him to
testify
he describes that they had to try to
shake mr
floyd awake several times long crime
daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome to long time daily everybody i'm
jesse weber in for brian buckmeyer who's
in minneapolis covering the derrick
chauvin trial
and with us of course is terry austin
week three of testimony in the high
profile trial now the plan is to
sequester the jury
once they start deliberating but brian
the defense is hoping to change that
right
that's right jesse just about 10 miles
from here
in brooklyn center a young man was shot
and killed by a police officer
now that's a separate city and a
separate police department
but that case seems to have implications
here the defense filed a motion to
sequester the jury monday morning
attorney eric nelson says at least one
juror lives in brooklyn center
and others have connections to the city
he was concerned civil unrest there
might pressure jurors to vote to not
convict because they do not want civil
unrest in minneapolis
prosecutors say it's a different case
and different department so sequestering
the jury wouldn't be appropriate
judge cahill denied the motion and
explained why he did so
the jurors all are aware and we're
concerned about their safety because of
what happened
in may of 2020. the civil unrest have
followed there
not a big surprise that there is now
civil unrest in response to this case
but i don't think that should heighten
the jurors
concern i think it's probably the same
as it was before
they all have a concern that they
expressed and we're very honest about
and so i'm not going to sequester them
we'll sequester them on monday when we
anticipate doing closings
so brian judge cahill says that the jury
won't be sequestered during testimony
but they will be after closing
arguments which are anticipated for next
monday what is that going to look like
yeah so that's probably going to look
like is they'll come in as they have
been
throughout the pendency both of the
opening statements and all
all the way through uh the testimony we
heard so far
but the judge is giving us an indication
that when the closing arguments begin
sometime next week as he pointed out um
that they're going to be sequestered for
that as well as
jury deliberation so they'll most likely
be posted up somewhere in a hotel here
and kept away from the public eye and
any kind of scrutiny
all right thanks brian day 11 of
testimony began with dr
jonathan rich a cardiologist called as
an expert by the state
now rich said this is his first time
testifying
in court after reviewing
all the facts and evidence of the case i
can state with a high degree of medical
certainty
that george floyd did not die from a
primary cardiac event
and he did not die from a drug overdose
did mr floyd have any diagnosis of heart
disease while he was still alive
no he did not and did you see at some
point that you're watching the video
that mr
floyd uh went into cardio pulmonary
arrest
eventually yes i did you could see at
least i could see
his speech starting to become
less forceful his muscle movements
becoming
weaker until of course eventually
his speech became absent eventually his
muscle movements were absent and then as
we later
discovered by the heart rhythm he was in
a pea cardiopulmonary arrest do you have
an opinion to a reasonable degree of
medical certainty
as to whether mr floyd's death was
preventable
yes i believe that mr george floyd's
death
was absolutely preventable
now the county's chief medical examiner
who performed the autopsy on george
floyd previously testified that floyd
had underlying heart disease including
including narrowing of arteries
now on cross-examination dr andrew baker
said that those factors
played a role in his death
he had 75 narrowing of the first
diagonal branch
of his left anterior descending coronary
artery and then in his right coronary
artery which in most people is the
second largest of the three
he had 90 proximal narrowing and what do
forensic pathologists generally consider
to be
enough narrowing of the arteries to
cause a sudden death
we usually look to 75 percent greater
as the is capable of causing sudden
death and so in
your opinion both the heart disease
as well as the history of hypertension
and the drug
the drugs that were in his system played
a role in mr floyd's death
in my opinion yes okay let's break it
down brian the cardiologist said that
floyd's heart was normal that's what
appeared to say but the medical examiner
said that
he had this underlying heart disease how
does that make sense
yeah so i think what the cardiologist is
basically saying is that
he's seen hearts like this before it's
not strange
unfortunately in america or north
america for someone to have a heart that
is a little bit larger
i'm 6'4 my heart's a little bit larger
as well than the average person because
surprise surprise i'm a little bit
taller than the average person
but also to see that they'll be blocking
in the heart and the interesting part
about what this witness testified to
was actually when there's partial
blockage in one part of the heart the
heart is this phenomenal muscle
that will help to correct it and ensure
that flow works in other ways as well
now terry here's the other thing because
on cross-examination
nelson asked dr baker about his
conversation with the henneman county
attorneys after
the death of george floyd but before dr
baker viewed the video
so did it seem to you that dr baker's
opinions may have
changed after he viewed the video i
think it did jesse
if you recall for the statements he made
to the hennepin county
attorney he was basically saying there
was no evidence of asphyxiation
he said that the heart condition was not
real
or was a contributing factor he
basically said that the level of
fentanyl
really could have caused the death of
someone else and that
if floyd had been home alone the
diagnosis could have been
a fentanyl overdose but we saw on the
direct examination and even on the
cross-examination
that he's basically backing away from
that and i do believe it was because
he did view the video and he did have a
slight change of opinion
as to the cause of death and ultimately
he said it was because of this law
enforcement
subdual restraint and neck compression
all right
interesting and see how the prosecution
ties it all together still ahead on long
crime daily
the police shooting of a man nearby to
the chauvin trial
and the newly released body cam video
but first
will the man seen in the car with george
floyd testify
or maurice hall has been in jail since
jury selection
and much more that you need to know next
[Music]
welcome back everybody the man who was
in george floyd's suv when he was
approached by police last may
appears in court on sex trafficking
charges long crimes anjanet levy is here
with what happened in maurice hall's
latest court appearance angenette
jesse maurice hall has already posted
bail in his four hennepin county cases
but now he has to post even more cash in
a case from another county he's not very
happy about it as
arguments about whether or not he'll
testify in the chauvin trial
continue
i just got shawanda hill and maurice
hall were in the suv with george floyd
as police approached last may
derek chovin's attorney says he needs
the jury to hear hall's testimony about
what happened that day
or portions of a 90-minute interview he
had with state
investigators he freely answered the
agent's questions
about where he and mr floyd
spent the day what his behavior what
their behaviors were where they
went the things that they did earlier in
the day
and specifically how he appeared
physically what his demeanor was
nelson says hall fled to texas right
after floyd died
investigators found him a week later at
that time nelson and prosecutors say
hall made incriminating statements when
interviewed
hall wants to invoke his fifth amendment
privilege against self-incrimination
his attorney said in court last week he
could put himself at
risk for being charged with third degree
murder if he gave drugs to george floyd
prosecutors say he could also be charged
with counterfeiting
there's a lot about mr hall's statement
that is
self-serving and unreliable
prosecutors say hall's interview with
investigators is hearsay
and doesn't meet exceptions to that rule
he denies
giving any pills to mr floyd denies that
he had pills
we know a lot of that is not
there's a lot of evidence that suggests
that's not true maurice hall
is in a lot of hot water legally he has
felony cases
pending in hennepin county and in
redwood county he's facing charges of
solicitation
sex trafficking in the second degree
promoting prostitution
and two counts of controlled substance
crimes involving methamphetamine
heroin fentanyl tramadol and other drugs
in court on those charges the judge told
hall he'd have to post 2 500
in cash to get out of jail to which hall
responded
that's f and nuts bro meanwhile
prosecutors in the chauvin trial have
not given hall immunity to testify
experts say hall's testimony only
benefits the defense
we're limiting those questions to just
in the car
correct cahill took a few
hours to mull this issue and he decided
that it would not be proper
for the jury to see that police
interview or to hear about it
um he doesn't want the jurors to see
that he said it's just not admissible
cahill also said that the state is not
required to give a reason as to why
they won't give maurice hall immunity
jesse
all right thanks angeannette now brian
if maurice hall takes the stand and
invokes his fifth amendment right
how will this move the case one way or
the other
i'm not quite sure this really helps
because the way i'm looking at it down
the line as a public defender in
brooklyn
if he testifies he's going to invoke the
fifth amendment for some very crucial
testimony
and of course as eric nelson should he
should point out that invoking that
right
is keeping away some information but if
derek chovin himself doesn't testify and
he does the exact same thing
i can see this backfiring him on him so
it might be
short-term gains but it could be a
long-term loss for the defense depending
on how this plays out
terry why do you think chauvin's
attorney is arguing to have maurice hall
testified does he really need his
testimony when we already
heard the testimony of courtney ross the
george floyd's girlfriend who confirmed
that george floyd
used drugs he does not need that
testimony it seems to me that it's
redundant
as you said we heard courtney ross
already talk about the fact
that george floyd took opioids took
fentanyl and we don't need to hear
maurice hall talk about that i think
that
what the defense is trying to do is
paint a picture that
these individuals were all using drugs
and they were addicts and he's trying to
literally victimize the victim and i
think one of the things the judge said
made a lot of sense he said that
paul's statements are not necessary for
a complete
defense so in the judge's opinion we
already have
all that we need to defend chovin
and those statements by hall are not
necessary now andrea it's my
understanding that hall
did admit to at least one crime in that
interview with bca agents can you speak
on that
yeah jesse he actually admitted
according to eric nelson
and the prosecutors they've they've all
seen this interview and read the
transcripts
that he possessed counterfeit bills that
day
now that's at the heart of this case
that is what got the ball rolling
here that's what started the police call
is that
20 bill that was believed to be
counterfeit and they believe he could
face some charges for that he could also
potentially face that third degree
murder charge should
should the prosecution decide to pursue
that but at this point
they are saying that he that that didn't
cause his death that that wasn't part of
it so
we'll just have to wait and see but he
did deny giving george floyd drugs
in that car that day so it'll be very
interesting to see how this plays out
important person in a complicated story
coming up on long crime daily
george floyd's brother testifies about
the loss of his loved one
plus the shocking police body cam video
released in the dante right shooting
why the chief is calling the fatal shot
an accident
up next
police in minnesota have released body
cam video showing the fatal shooting of
a man over the weekend
which has sparked protests long primes
kim johnson is in minneapolis and has
the latest
kim jesse as if
tensions couldn't get any higher during
derrick shovin's murder trial here in
minneapolis
they have and by a lot another
death of a black man in the hands of
police this time in brooklyn center
minnesota a town that shares a border
with minneapolis and is
not far from here just miles away from
the courthouse
we want to warn you that the body-worn
camera footage
is graphic it shows an officer fatally
shooting
20-year-old dante wright during a
traffic stop for expired
tabs during a press conference brooklyn
center police chief
tim gannon says that he believes the
shooting
was accidental
[Music]
during this encounter however the
officer drew their handgun
instead of their taser as i watched the
video and listened to the officer's
commands
it is my belief that the officer had the
intention to deploy their taser
but instead shot mr wright with a single
bullet
now the officer is now on administrative
duty but the mayor of brooklyn center
says he thinks the officer
should be fired just as in former
officer chauvin's case the state bureau
of criminal apprehension
will now take over the investigation now
immediately
after this shooting peaceful protests
some of them
did turn violent and some businesses
here were
looted in light of that chauvin's
defense team has
asked the judge to sequester the jury
for any possible tainting
or exposure and the judge has denied
that request
arguing that the two cases are
completely
separate jesse and kim have you seen any
protests around the courthouse
specifically
well in light of this shooting no not
near the pro
or not near the courthouse yet however
uh
i suspect that could change especially
since
the defense is about to take over and
present its case and its arguments i
have already seen
previous protesters here around the
courthouse specifically
calling out defense attorney eric nelson
some of the arguments
that he has made and they have not been
happy with that so i suspect the more we
hear
from nelson and his arguments
we could see more protesters here around
the courthouse in downtown minneapolis
pretty incredible stay safe kim thank
you when we come back
back into the courtroom for the derek
chauvin trial as george floyd's brother
takes the stand
[Music]
prosecutors in the derrick chauvin trial
called george floyd's brother to the
stand
as part of a minnesota law known as
spark of life testimony intended to
humanize floyd
to the jurors he used to make the best
banana mayonnaise sandwiches and he used
to make syrup sandwiches
because george couldn't cook he couldn't
boil water
he loved sports so he always wanted to
be the best
as my mother she's no longer with us
right now but
that's my oldest brother george
i miss both of them they are
i was married in may 24th
i got married and my brother was killed
may 25th and my mom died on may 30th
it's like a bittersweet month because
i'm supposed to be happy when a mom
comes
prosecutors went on to ask it more about
their mother and the impact her death
had on their lives he was a big mama's
boy
um i cried a lot but george she loved
this mom he will
always just be up under her hand you
know every mother loves all of her kids
but it was so
unique how they were with each other
he showed us like uh how
to treat our mom and how to respect our
mom
he he just he loved her so
dearly when we went to the funeral
it's just george just sat there at the
casket
over and over again he would just say
mama
mama over and over again and
i didn't know what to tell them because
i was in pain too we all were hurt
brian the defense didn't cross-examine
philonous floyd and why do you think
that was
i think it was two things it was a
strategic move i i think
everyone kind of felt felonious uh
floyd's testimony um
especially this mama's boy i think
everyone kind of understands the mama's
boy kind of
um just feeling and especially if you
are one
and then the other thing is from us from
a legal standpoint
mr floyd or felonious floyd didn't open
the door to any permis
impermissible testimony if he had said
george floyd is a gentle giant or a
peaceful person
you would have seen eric nelson jump on
that and rebut that with their own
evidence
and so because there was no real opening
there and this is not a witness you want
to cross-examine i think nelson
did the right move here terry the
prosecution called philonous floyd as i
said as a spark of life witness this
legal definition
do you think he was effective for that
strategy
i do think he was effective although i
will say i think that the prosecution
could have gone into
a little bit more detail i know you have
to be careful so you don't open
the door for the cross-examination but
he talked about the fact that they came
from an underprivileged area the fact
that
he made these sandwiches for all of the
siblings and the fact that george floyd
was very close
to his mother so i think the jury felt
that what he
could have done also is to use bolognese
floyd as a witness to talk about what is
george like now what are his children
like what kind of father
is he so the jury could get a better
feel for the type of person he was
right before he died so i do think there
was a little bit more
but i definitely think that for the jury
george floyd's personality was humanized
at least to a certain extent
and it's important to have these spark
of life witnesses because we've heard
george floyd
in a headline as a statistic as just a
symbol but to really understand
who he was on a day-in day-out basis
it gives the jurors a different
perspective that they might not have had
otherwise
terry bryan thank you thanks for joining
us here on long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you